tim is the worst the other day he like
saw me eating my apple and he's like so
you don't cut your Apple first in Tim I
don't do any of my own work because I'm
a jerk the other day he asked me to like
oh god I shouldn't have made fun of Tim
like that what if someone in the coffee
shop heard me and his friends with him
what if I get fired cuz he finds out
what I've said because I want to get to
know him I prayed he just has a tough
time at work here's your change
$2 have a good day awesome thank you
have a good one they gave me the wrong
change should I take it what if I get
arrested and in prison for life all
because I decided to take an extra
dollar from this gentle mom-and-pop shop
no no you know what no I'm sorry
you gave me three dollars not two
dollars and I was gonna take it I wasn't
being taken here take this take it you
know what actually know who deserve all
my money I'm a terrible person I'm so
sorry oh my god I can't believe I did
that she's gonna hate me for that Oh God
I am so sorry I even no I'm so sorry so
so sorry
Oh God
everyone knows we built the milk look
I'm staring at me I still don't work I
did it for you today I'm good
Stephen how are you it's pronounced to
fun oh my god I'm so sorry
that must happen to you all the time and
I'm adding to that I'm really truly
sorry I'm really sorry about earlier
Stephane got it right that time huh I'm
really sorry
hey Stu fine but we are closing why
haven't you started cleaning up yet oh
this woman dropped some straws and she
offered to clean the whole place hey
sorry again
Oh
I'm sorry